[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag bonjour à
tous bienvenue sur sensation en
association avec TV 78 je suis
aujourd'hui avec Caroline Faivre
fondatrice et présidente de Versailles
zéro déchet bonjour bonjour alors votre
association semble sensibilise et fait
de la prévention autour du zéro déchet
du respect de l'environnement quels sont
vos objectifs au quotidien envers les
citoyens alors c'est d'expliquer en quoi
c'est important de de réduire ses
déchets donc c'est pas mettre l'accent
sur le recyclage parce que le recyclage
c'est une solution mais ce qu'un le plus
important pour nous c'est d'éviter de
produire des déchets parce que le slogan
qu'on utilise c'est le meilleur déchet
celui qu'on ne produit pas voilà donc
c'est l'expliquer en quoi c'est
important et comment on peut le faire
sans que ce soit trop contraignant au
quotidien et vous abordez plusieurs
thématiques au sein de votre association
comme le recyclage le psykling
l'utilisation de compost et la réduction
des déchets pourquoi cette thématique
doivent être mises en avant et doivent
faire l'objet d'une sensibilisation
envers les citoyens ce qu'il y a une
urgence finalement aujourd'hui oui alors
le volume de un fichier produit à
doubler sur les 40 dernières années donc
on est vraiment envahi de déchets en
plus donc il y a beaucoup de avec tout
le plastique à usage unique a été mis en
place donc le nombre le nombre et le
volume de déchets se multiplier et les
modes de traitement des déchets donc
soit l'incinération ou la mise en
décharge ont tous les deux des impacts
environnementaux donc à l'heure actuelle
que ce soit avec le réchauffement
climatique ou l'érosion de la
biodiversité c'est vraiment des
thématiques qui est urgent de traiter
voilà parmi les sujets que vous abordez
il y a le gaspillage alimentaire
concrètement qu'est-ce que c'est le
gaspillage alimentaire est-ce que c'est
un problème aujourd'hui qui dont on
s'occupe enfin dont on se préoccupe plus
qu'il y a 30 ou 40 ans
alors donc le gaspillage alimentaire
qu'est-ce que c'est en fait c'est toute
la nourriture qui est produite
et qui n'est pas consommé par par qui
est produite pour l'alimentation humaine
et qui n'est pas consommé donc qui va
partir à la poubelle et ce en fait aux
différentes étapes de la chaîne de
production parce qu'on pense souvent au
gaspillage alimentaire au niveau des
restaurants de la restauration
collective ou même à la maison mais en
fait le gaspillage alimentaire il
commence dès l'étape de production avec
par exemple
la surpêche donc des poissons qui sont
pêchés mais qui vont être rejetés
directement parce que c'est pas ce qu'on
consomme avec les fruits et légumes qui
sont arcalibres au moment de il y a
l'étape de transformation au niveau
duquel il y a du gaspillage aussi par
exemple
transformation et distribution par
exemple rupture de la chaîne du froid
donc les produits vont être écartés ou
alors si ils sont pas beaux ils sont mal
emballés etc ils vont être écartés
également et puis le gaspillage
alimentaire à domicile ou au niveau de
la restauration donc à tous les étages
et ça représente c'est ça qui est énorme
comme chiffre 30% de la nourriture qui
est produite pour l'alimentation humaine
et gaspiller est-ce qu'il faut est-ce
qu’important à garder en tête c'est que
l'impact environnemental
de l'alimentation c'est au niveau de la
production qui est le plus important
donc même si on compost ou on trouve une
solution à peu près
satisfaisante pour traiter ces déchets
là en fait on a utilisé beaucoup de
ressources de l'énergie de l'eau de
l'espace de la place il faut de la place
pour faire pousser des des légumes des
fruits etc qui vont être pour rien en
fait parce que c'est c'est ces choses-là
vont être gaspillés derrière oui pas
seulement le gaspillage alimentaire
finalement dans ce dans cette production
et dans cette consommation des produits
c'est c'est tout un ensemble finalement
où il faut faire attention c'est
vraiment réduire à tous les niveaux de
la chaîne de la production à la
consommation voilà et alors selon selon
la dame mais je vais reprendre un
finalement vos termes que vous avez très
bien expliqué la perte et le gaspillage
alimentaire représente 10 millions de
tonnes de produits par an 30 kg par
personne et par an en ce qui concerne le
gaspillage alimentaire dans sa phase de
consommation le gaspillage alimentaire
justement n'est pas effectif seulement
lors de la consommation vous l'avez dit
32% en phase de production de enfin 32%
de perte en face de production 21 % en
face de transformation et 14 en face de
distribution est-ce qu'on peut
réellement définir les principales
causes du gaspillage alimentaire au sein
d'un foyer par exemple alors au sein
d'un foyer en général ça va être une
mauvaise gestion entre guillemets
mauvaise des dates de péremption voilà
on va avoir acheté trop par rapport à ce
qu'on consomme
ou alors on va avoir dépassé la date
limite de consommation et donc les
produits vont finir à la poubelle ou
alors pour les fruits et légumes on va
en avoir acheté plus que ce qu'on
consomme et du coup ils vont se s'abîmer
et on les jette à la poubelle donc c'est
surtout ça la effectivement ça
représente à peu près 30 kg et c'est un
coup derrière puisque 30 kg il y a
quelques années ça représentait déjà 108
euros par personne et par an donc à
multiplier par le nombre des personnes
du foyer aujourd'hui avec l'inflation ça
doit être encore plus donc c'est non
négligeable sur un budget et ce
gaspillage alimentaire il a également un
coup à un produit jeté ou gaspiller
c'est bien entendu de l'argent perdu et
vous l'avez vous l'avez dit quels sont
les solutions possibles pour éviter au
maximum le gaspillage alimentaire vous
avez parlé d'une mauvaise gestion des
courses par exemple est-ce que ça c'est
déjà une solution alors mauvaise gestion
je vais pas culpabiliser les gens c'est
effectivement on peut déjà
faire une liste de courses avant d'aller
faire les courses donc il y a des c'est
des petites astuces ça peut paraître
toute bête mais regardez ce qu'on a dans
ces placards et dans son frigo pour pour
faire sa liste de courses éviter de se
laisser teinter par les promotions sur
les packs en particulier parce que ça
peut paraître alléchant se dit c'est pas
cher mais si la moitié finit à la
poubelle au final on aura payé plus que
si on avait pas été séduit par cette
promotion donc vraiment sans tenir à ce
qu'il y a sur sa liste on dit par
exemple aussi éviter d'aller faire les
courses si on a faim parce qu'on va se
laisser tenter par plein de choses
voilà donc
et puis effectivement dans son frigo on
peut aussi mettre en avant les produits
qui sont interminés en premier en
fonction de la date de consommation etc
après il y a des il y a des applications
aussi qui existent où on peut faire des
recherches sur internet pour
faire son menu en fonction de ce qu'on a
dans son placard ou son frigo donc on va
noter 3 3 ingrédients qu'on a et qu'on
doit terminer et on peut comme ça
trouver des recettes à faire avec ça
pour vider son frigo vider son placard
et une des solutions est-ce que c'est
par exemple je pense notamment à une
application qui existe pour faire des
recettes en fonction de ce qu'on a dans
le football on utilise par exemple les
produits qui vont à terme ou la date de
péremption va arriver quand on se rend
compte que quelque chose entre
guillemets traîne dans le frigo et ben
effectivement on peut utiliser ces
outils là pour pour faire des recettes
et puis aussi il y a quelque chose
d'assez important c'est manger ses
restes
si on si on voit que son pain par
exemple est en train de sécher donc on
peut le mettre au congélateur sinon on
peut en faire de la chapelure on peut
s'il reste des choses on peut les garder
pour un repas suivant déjà c'est
économique ça permet de gagner du temps
puisqu'on n'a pas besoin de le cuisiner
voilà de cuisiner à nouveau voilà donc
il y a plein d'idées de recettes qui
peuvent être faites avec à base de reste
donc je sais pas un reste de légumes on
peut le réutiliser dans une tarte dans
une omelette enfin voilà peut-être petit
truc comme ça pour pour éviter de jeter
des bananes abîmées on peut les utiliser
pour faire un fabriquer un gâteau il y a
plein de choses à faire pour pour éviter
de jeter quelque chose qui s'abîme alors
on l'a compris le gaspillage alimentaire
ne commence pas finalement au sein d'un
foyer il est sur sur plusieurs plusieurs
échelles en France et en Europe
l'environnement est une thématique qui
revient souvent quel est le rôle que les
institutions et les élus nationaux ont à
jouer justement contre le gaspillage
alimentaire
et bien ils peuvent mettre enfin faire
en sorte de
mettre des lois contraignantes par
exemple c'est ce qui a permis de
d'obliger entre guillemets et les
supermarchés à donner leurs invendus
alimentaires alors c'est pas parfait
parce que il faut qu'il y ait des
associations qui puissent les récupérer
etc donc ça marche c'est pas fait
systématiquement mais ça permet déjà de
limiter les dégâts entre guillemets donc
la loi qui oblige les supermarchés de
plus je crois que c'est plus de 400 m² à
donner ses invendus alimentaires
donc ça c'est des choses qui vont dans
le bon sens donc les élus peuvent aller
dans le sens de la contrainte voilà pour
obliger les producteurs distributeurs à
limiter les déchets
on a aussi cette cette nouvelle tendance
ou les produits à date de péremption
courte finalement sont vendus donc à
moins cher ça aussi c'est une solution
efficace c'est une solution efficace on
peut les mettre en tête de gondole si
c'est pas fait dans le magasin où vous
faites les courses n'hésitez pas à en
parler aux gérant enfin aux personnel
les mettre avec un prix un peu bradé et
en tête de gondole c'est c'est
effectivement intéressant pour pour
limiter le gaspillage alimentaire il y a
aussi des applications qui se mettent en
place pour récupérer des paniers enfin
des applications ou même certains
magasins qui font des paniers avec les
produits qui arrivent à date courte ou
les fruits et légumes qui commencent à
être un peu abîmés donc c'est vraiment
du très peu cher c'est un moyen de faire
des économies alors effectivement il
faut peut-être cuisiner un peu plus
derrière mais c'est voilà c'est une
façon de réduire le gaspillage
alimentaire de faire des économies et ça
peut être mis en place assez facilement
par les par les magasins et on a aussi
c'est publicités avec des légumes moches
les consommateurs sont incités à acheter
des légumes moches là aussi c'est encore
une solution et pourquoi un légume moche
enfin un légume moche ne veut pas dire
moins bon finalement qu'un beau même
parfois ils ont parfois plus de goût
enfin d'ailleurs quand on quand on
jardine et qu'on mange ses fruits et
légumes qu'on produit on les mange quel
que soit la tête qu'ils ont donc non
c'est parce qu'il y a une espèce
d'habitude marketing effectivement les
fruits légumes bien ronds bien bien
colorés vont attirer plus facilement que
le client que les autres mais ils ont
pas forcément plus de goût et on peut on
peut finir c'est interview en concluant
que il faut consommer il faut faire
attention à notre mode de consommation
et faire une liste déjà c'est déjà un
bon début pour pour faire attention au
gaspillage alimentaire merci beaucoup
Caroline fièvre d'avoir été avec nous
sur sensation je rappelle donc vous êtes
la présidente est fondatrice de
Versailles zéro déchet et pour revoir ou
réécouter cette émission rendez-vous sur
notre site et notre application radio
sensation
[Musique]